oh my god call the police there's candy
in here there is candy Kim and Kourtney
Kardashian butt heads over their
daughters birthday bash I'm really
freaking out everyone's gonna come to
this party and everything is gonna be
disgusting chemicals we need to have
some coffee at the party in a teaser for
season 17 of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians the sisters are seen getting
into an explosive fight over Northwest
and Penelope Disick's joint birthday
there's no reason that you can't have
the theme of the party and have treats
that are its Candy Land
there's candies that are not disgusting
and filled with chemicals show me some
court who is known for her healthy
lifestyle doesn't want traditional candy
given out to the kids
you're like dated you're like in the
pocket candy land theme party
yes that's like what the party is about
candy land it's not gluten-free land
over here clearly the pair made amends
as we saw last month the candy land
theme party went on as planned
and of course the reality stars took to
their IG stories to give us an inside
look at the soiree which featured a
giant board game path across the
backyard a bounce house and all the
sugar you can imagine mr. softy is here
and mine already melted but I mean let's
not forget about North and Penelope's
candy filled rainbow cake needless to
say there were a lot of sugar highs that
day whether court liked it or not